[Applause]
los angeles ramp star taylor rapp pops
the question just moments after winning
super bowl 56
but the rams were built
to win the super bowl
and they have sealed the deal
after that history-making moment the
safety got down on one knee presenting
girlfriend danny johnson with an
engagement ring and the crowd couldn't
get enough check out all the onlookers
cheering on danny's yes
[Applause]
[Music]
as the 24 year old football pro put it
on his instagram story he ended his
sunday with not one but two rings
[Music]
[Music]
taylor wasn't the only ram to walk away
with a little extra to celebrate after
the super bowl we're going to celebrate
man i'm i'm like i said i'm so
overwhelmed we're going to celebrate my
teammates tonight my wife is having a
baby tonight
i gotta go to the hospital and see her
but i'm gonna celebrate with my
teammates man and celebrate with my wife
too yup wide receiver van jefferson
became a dad of two immediately after
the team's big win
the 25 year old went straight from the
field to the hospital after his wife
samaria went into labor at sofie stadium
that's where van shared this sweet
snapshot cradling his newborn son baby
boy makes the jefferson bunch a family
of four van and samaria are already
parents to a five-year-old daughter
bella and speaking of daughters check
out this funny moment for rams team
captain andrew whitworth yes that's
andrew's seven-year-old kiddo catherine
reading a book instead of watching her
dad secure his first ever super bowl win
oh it's special she you know she's the
fourth one and and you know what the
hardest one that's that's her i mean she
just she's so cool she's just her in
every moment and that's what makes her
special and and you know what it it it's
that fourth one that's just the
strongest the toughest
and uh who she is the most out of all of
them and that's why we love her so much
and love was certainly in the air during
this combo super bowl valentine's
weekend bachelor alum hannah ann sloss
went instagram official with her beau
rams player jake funk hannah shared this
good luck kiss for jake on instagram
before he faced off with the cincinnati
bengals bachelor fans will recall hannah
was previously engaged to peter webber
torn and conflicted peter all throughout
next step by your side
and you took the most precious moment
that i could ever imagine
away from me
because to officially just did not want
me to walk away
we're gonna send me home what whatever
the case would have been
you're right
nearly two years after that split
shocked bachelor nation the reality star
is soaking up her new bose success
hannah posted this look behind the
scenes at sophie stadium during jake's
first ever super bowl she also took her
followers along for the rams family
after party festivities
[Music]
congrats to the la rams on their big win
[Music]